I've never really considered myself much
of a collector but then one game came
along and basically changed all of it
it's a Japanese survival horror game
from 1999 for the Sega Dreamcast and
it's called D2 and it's responsible for
two things my obsession with collecting
other Japanese called horror games and
learning that retro games in Japan are
so damn cheap do a search on eBay for D2
and you will see just how expensive that
game can go for the Japanese version on
the other hand goes for just mere
dollars and it ain't just D2 whether
it's the Clock Tower series Echo night
ill bleed enemy zero you name it there's
always one consistent thing the American
ones are stupid expensive when the
Japanese ones are just ridiculously
cheap the thing is I became absolutely
consumed in trying to understand this
ridiculous price Gap and I think there's
a few to explain it and what better way
to kick this all off than going to the
source
[Music]
I'm Kurt and I have never been to Japan
until today
this was my first time here and I was
completely alone and while I was here to
work in my downtime my agenda was simple
wander aimlessly eat and of course go
shopping for video games and where
better to start than Japan's electronic
District Akihabara games were everywhere
and I mean like everywhere there was
bins just out on the streets filled with
video games and when I did finally walk
into a video game store it had only been
a matter of minutes until I found
everything I had been obsessing over and
yes they were by American Standards
incredibly cheap not to mention a lot of
these games were complete in their box
and sealed D2 was right next to c-man
and oh there was also a copy of D's
Diner on the 3DO sealed and yes I bought
foreign from this experience just being
able to walk into one store after the
other and see a multitude of these games
of course the first and most obvious
speculation was mass production these
games were made for Japanese audience
there are likely to be more popular in
Japan therefore more copies of them were
made than they were in North America
which is a totally reasonable thing to
speculate but there is something else
that stood out to me while I was there
that wasn't just mass production the
culture of physical media
so considering the amount of shops I've
been in so far including the bookstore
that I just aimlessly wandered into this
store felt like it had thousands of
movies a
Deeds to choose from and when I realized
it was rental something that was
basically extinct in the states it made
me start thinking about this entire idea
of why games could be cheaper a little
differently here whether it's consoles
toppled on top of each other or endless
rows of games and movies it didn't feel
novel or like something to be coveted
they sort of felt meaningless
but not in a way that like they don't
matter but rather just how I'm used to
seeing games treated here in the states
which are often like collectors items in
fact the closest thing we're feeling I
can relate it to actually is second hand
bookstores walking through game stores
in Japan is a stark contrast to what it
feels like to walk into a game store in
America it felt more like I was
rummaging through places like this it's
the same feeling it's a place filled
with hundreds of books from classics to
obscure ones most of which you can buy
for a few bucks Just Books upon books
stacked on top of each other or found in
bins on the street like games in Japan
the value isn't in what the price tag
says it's what's in the pages it's
what's in the case which ties back to
exactly what sent me down this rabbit
hole in the first place
thank you
[Music]
I didn't want D2 because it was a
collector's item or because it was
expensive I wanted it because I have an
infatuation with its writer director and
composer Kenji Ina every game this dude
has made is off-kilter and
unconventional in its design and D2 was
no exception it was also his last major
game that he wrote directed and composed
before he died in 2013. on the back of
the case of D2 it says a terrifying
Adventure unlike anything ever
experienced and you know what it is
absolutely right its pacing as slow and
brooding its horror as Brash and intense
and yet the combat is almost arcadey it
is a hodgepodge of ideas and while it
may not work for everyone it certainly
landed with me because like the back of
the case says I will likely never play a
game like this from AAA Studio from a
major publisher ever again and it was
these experiences that got me excited
over the idea of collecting new and
weird and wacky things the value and me
owning it was as sort of like a symbol
or an Ode to an artist that I deeply
respected and in turn it also inspired
me to want to find more games like it
that were often older Japanese and
extremely expensive and aside from being
expensive all the games I've mentioned
have one other specific thing in common
they're apparently like not that good
and you know what
I don't care
[Music]
being in Japan for a short time and
being able to get that first-hand
experience of how easy these games were
to track down it honestly kind of bummed
me out you would think there would be at
least one Retro Game Store in San
Francisco they exist just outside of the
city and if I want to go to one I'd have
to get in the car and drive for around
an hour to get to any of them and guess
what
this guy doesn't have a car when in
comparison games in Tokyo just seem to
be culturally infused nearly anywhere I
wandered in the city it didn't take long
to just find a store that sold games it
really gave me a chance to see just how
differently games seem to be viewed here
because that's what has sunk in in the
states games are treated like baseball
cards like Collectibles like flipped
sneakers and I mean that literally
there's a flea market I go to every
single month and without fail there are
always vendors selling all those things
every single time I go in some cases the
sellers didn't entirely know the value
of what they were selling they just knew
that games were valuable and that's
where I keep coming back to this
juxtaposition the games found at flea
markets and these vacant parking lots
that are just astronomically expensive
by my standards versus the games I found
on the streets of Tokyo that look like
they've been kicked around and for a
fraction of the price and especially
specifically I'm kind of referring to
that sun bleach copy of Super Mario 64.
something that can be bought by someone
for just a few bucks and cherished the
same exact way I cherish some of my
favorite books that look like they've
been ran over and kicked on the street
600 times both of which the game and the
books I'm referring to have probably
been played or read sold and re-bought a
dozen times now putting cultural reasons
aside why we're in the situation we're
in concerning the prices of games really
stems from the game grading bubble that
inflated in 2021 when wada games a
Grading Company sold a copy of Super
Mario Brothers for 2 million dollars and
when that happened despite game grading
being a whole beast in of itself the
public eye saw a headline that saw a
game that sold for two million dollars
and therefore the general public view of
games was that they were valuable that
they were expensive alongside comic
books and beanie babies and coins or
whatever else people decide to collect
which is how we end up with people
selling boxed Sega Saturns at flea
markets for 600 when in comparison when
I was in Japan every single game store I
walked into had walls made of consoles
for sale that were at affordable prices
I'm pretty sure I saw like a Dreamcast
for like 40 bucks also it was only days
before I started searching to purchase
D2 which means that Super Mario Brothers
copy sold and then I just was like I
just want my weird little game and
that's of course of course when the
price skyrocketed and a good way to
actually like visually see how all this
happened as a site called
pricecharting.com which accumulates all
the sold version of a game and then you
can actually see the actual chart of
when these games skyrocketed in price in
all that being set aside it's not like
I'm trying to say it's worth going to
Japan just because games are so much
cheaper to buy instead this whole thing
gave me the opportunity to reflect on my
relationship with collecting and why I
even collect in the first place for
every single person there's going to be
a very specific likely intimate reason
as to why they collect the things they
collect that could be for Nostalgia that
could be for preserving the medium it
could even be a sign of their identity
how they even represent themselves as a
person in my case I collect a lot of
things I collect either to honor a
specific artist because that thing had
some sort of influence on who I am or
you know I just like to preserve those
lost gems that I think are culturally
interesting even though you know not
if there's one thing I could at least
confirm is that Japan just does not have
a retro gaming bubble like the one we do
but all of this
that's just my perspective
you let me know
[Music]
foreign